yes apples go ahead you're on the air in
colorado apples everyone knows apples
well i love ronnie he did something
really cool this weekend
he drove a thousand horsepower mercedes
and i would really love to know more
about that
how do you know that i saw it on his
social media
ronnie i know you don't like apples is
this true and
are you upset with him for stalking you
i don't think he's stalking you
well yeah uh how is he how is he how is
he seeing it if he's
if he's blocked from our stuff
ronnie ronnie i love you pal um i'm just
a fan
why doesn't he answer the question
howard why doesn't he answer the
question
there's there's a lot of way just ways
to see your stuff people send me
you bother the fans to send you [ __ ]
about me
because you're a freaking weirdo dude
i'm sorry you're a weirdo
are you serious you're putting it out on
social media and you don't know how he
gets a hold of it
anybody can send somebody yeah listen
if people were bothered they wouldn't be
sending it to him they like this
yeah okay good fine you don't know that
they're gonna send them your stuff don't
put it out driving a mercedes yes and i
i did i put it up okay apples how do you
feel about ronnie driving a mercedes
i thought it was [ __ ] awesome what is
it was it a cl63
don't worry about what it is it's a
mercedes it's a high-end like a black
model eight
thousand thousand hours i know plenty
about mercedes pal
good i'm glad was it was it amg
don't worry about what it was wait
apples i'll ask ronnie
hey ron i heard you were driving a
mercedes what kind
a mercedes yeah but what time was it
brand new mercedes completely customized
wow what kind a mercedes
what else you want to know apples i'm
having a dialogue
ronnie what's the coolest car you've
ever driven ever
what's going on anybody else want to
know the answer to that question you can
ask
ronnie what's the coolest car you ever
drove
kurt bush's ford gt wow
to the gold rush rally that's all i mean
i got the answer by asking
yeah i don't even know know why you
entertain this guy dude
i really do you know why because apples
i don't know what you're seeing here man
i'll tell you what i know what i know
what you see in him what do i see
what do i say you don't even hate me no
wrong
wrong yes wrong yes he's it's your
show i don't care but i don't have to be
involved with him
he's a freaking weirdo and you don't
just don't get it
he just wants to know what kind of
mercedes you were driving he's a weirdo
dude i'm sorry
what's so weird about it this guy has
issues
you know what ron apples is like uh like
superman hates lex luthor
apples is like your lex luthor you're
absolutely right
yeah you don't even know